he's learning already
he's learning to not put the can down
too hard on the table this is a man
who's watched some podcasts anyway but
everyone who's listening welcome back
honey Webster's join you today how are
you very well thank you what's happening
long drive today
long drive five hours in car decent
training session considering very decent
training session and worth it obviously
beseeming of course the later part of
tonight's antic yes of course those of
you who know what I
how I perceive drinking I'm gonna
suspend my drinking habits or my lack of
drinking habits for one evening I
kidding the holy man when I met you six
months ago right Easton yeah exactly
and we still went out and you were there
like it was difficult but that was at
the end of it that was like I'm like
dude we used to go yeah it was not easy
but yeah that was that was still a
really fun night at body-to-body parents
so gigs religion that like a few hours
before as then we just like click yeah
it's cool man it's awesome so anyone
who's watching on the brand-new modern
wisdom youtube channel subscribe
subscribe subscribe if you don't know
what Sony does video man teen will make
it appear here and here and also here
so Sony is an Olympic weightlifter
represented Great Britain at real yep
2016 and now you are traveling the
world's doing weightlifting seminars and
coaching people doing a lot PT work a
lot of them having an awful lot of fun
and being a big dick Instagram swinger
and all the rest of this stuff man
so to the people who don't know who you
are and for the people who do can you
give us a background how did you start
in weightlifting where does it go where
do you be able I guess have to take you
right back to me even as a kid and
go back and talk about I guess what got
me into sport and I mean I've always
been sports kid you know you get those
kids the sporty kids and then you have
kids more artistic et cetera I was
always a sporty kid my dad was always
into golf so naturally before I could
pretty much walk my dad at golf
cut my hands and even remember like he
still got videos that on you know the
old video recorders like the tapes of
him trying to teach many so brutal with
me my golf swing is pure and he's like
that's wrong it's bad number three years
old yeah so my dad was like was pushing
me with my sport and going back to sort
of like year when did you start like
primary school yeah I've you're five
years old yeah so from primary school
really upsetting that goes up to what
year sixth isn't it so during that time
of school I was in like all the sort of
school perps like Jim not gymnastics
you know athletics the cricket ball
throw was my event
I've a to me a sprint until we get to
year six and it became one hundred and I
like talking me kill of me I was always
like little like stocky like those two
my mom's from New Zealand's have got bit
marry me so like that stocky sort of
build and I'd be like Oh without the
first look 40 then I'd hang on because
me as as soon as it became like hundred
me is I was finished it was always about
being the fastest kid in school was what
I was a loser yeah that finished me
there I tried hideout obviously these
little stumps and look at that long jump
was okay but again not great and slowly
realized that I was the kid that was
good at lots of things but great nothing
yeah and always tell stories there's one
like key point for me in I guess my
limpet journey if you like that stands
out for me I don't know it is about this
moment but it's still like sticks in my
head
I remember being sat in math class in
school yeah I would have been war year
five probably and it's I'm gonna say mm
and maybe it's 2002 and I'm sat in maths
class doing maths and in the way that my
school was it was like three classrooms
and they were divided by that side into
doors and the PE teacher from running in
burst open one of these side doors like
stop but got to turn the TV on and there
was only one TV in in the school and so
we were like right fine like I better to
bet the mask or watch the TV
and mr. cousins I think the Petey's name
was and she flipped the TV on and it was
right at the moment when David Beckham
and Kelly Holmes was jumping up and down
hugging each other
but do you know that well I'm on about
no okay so it's right when we won the
bid for London 2012 Olympics cuz I'll
see them - were like keep because yeah
of like the end of the campaign yeah the
campaign so um that moment just sticks
out for me as something it was like my
first real recollection of the Olympics
and what it was I don't know is about
that moment but it's still that makes me
feel happy now but it was just how much
it meant to them made me feel from that
right from that moment like I want to be
part of that I want that feeling
whatever that is and after them for the
next sort of couple of weeks I guess in
school they did a lot of like classes
around the Olympics what was top see
educate us as to what the Olympic Games
was and at that time I could could told
you every golfer in the top ten but knew
nothing about what were you know any
Olympic sports to learn all that and I
guess then we go into year six again I
continued with the sports I was doing
and you know
punya saw along and then we ended up
moving down from year six two years
seven down to a school in Ivybridge so
this was back in reading and dance I've
Richards a little town in Devon near
Plymouth
you already are sender the country there
yeah oh yeah true true but yep long
pretty safe yeah so it started four
years six years seven then at this new
school and naturally when you start new
school and you don't know anyone you
kind of like that learner and at the
time I was living with my dad when we
moved down how many first were down
there and I remember like my first day
at this school and like you know how
like you mum makes you Pat lunches and
she can cuz it's your mum and yet they
know how to make Pat lunch yeah and then
it was like my dad was making me this
Pat lunch and like bless me try too hard
but st. Sweden [ __ ] use today so you
just roll you into screaming a single
begotten like yeah pretty much like yeah
go in the shop and get what you want
you're like no slice my sandwiches
before I goes bad so I just remember
that first day be like a surrender going
to cry yeah she had like starting this
new school and just being like oh cuz
it's friendless yeah [ __ ]
new school and it's big school as well
okay and it was very zyb rich Community
College and its really well renowned
known for its sport mm-hmm
which is half the reason why we went in
that and it's like a community college
so is like a normal public school not
private yeah
and yes I starred in this in this school
no mate
spy ship at lunch and I decided at lunch
times and that I'd go and sit in the
weightlifting gym and your school had a
weightlifting gym yes and there used to
be very rare I'd probably be able to
count the number of schools in one handy
too at the time when I started there's
only two schools in the country that
offered weightlifting as part of the
GCSE curriculum so you could do it as
like a it's part of your PE GCSE that's
amazing yeah yeah only to the other one
wasn't berming I think Baba stop I say
yeah really rare to come across this but
we did have also a Golf Academy even it
in that back school as well so by the
in the summer I eventually joined the
Kolkata me as well anyway so I went and
sat in this weightlifting gym and I
guess each year maybe 60 or 70 students
sign up to wait the thing Club at
lunchtime from year 7 but I wasn't
really interested I was just like
killing my lunch times basically yeah
watching people do it because nothing
else right so I guess I've been efening
two weeks before the coach mutts me said
that you've been in out two weeks you're
weeding everyone else you're weirding
everyone out you're also attacking that
pack lunches [ __ ] yeah you're taking
the piss out of like some of the kids
giving it a go and the coaches just kind
of like come over yourself yeah or [ __ ]
off basically take your [ __ ] back one
yeah so I was like at the time that I
didn't know that it was an Olympic sport
and I wasn't really like for me sort of
thing I was I'm I'm a golfer whatever
and the coach said that now come on we
got to come tomorrow at lunchtime like
and I thought like so I've had my artist
says that [ __ ] it up girl on happy go to
the next lunch time I went along and
purely because I sat there watching
people do it like anything if you watch
something do it enough you have a pretty
good idea of what you need to do and I'd
done that and after the first session
the coach mode to me and said like did
that the other coach teacher do that was
it
no no I've just been watching like I
knew I need to do and they're like she
was up sore fingers she was like um you
got detention every lunchtime do you
want to be here essentially he said
that's how I spent the rest of my time
in the school was practicing the weight
of thing and it started off so fell into
it by chance but then it started off
just being like a lunchtime thing I'd go
in for an hour of lunch and do my weight
lifting and I made some friends through
that so then it became something that we
do get up and go and do an hour before
school and then it became about before
school
time and after school and yeah I mean
within the first I moved my first
competition which is that six months
after I started and it was actually at
my school and I remember crying because
I didn't didn't get all my left's I
think I got five out of my 6 lifts it's
like crying what a perfectionist at an
early age then yes always yeah that's I
guess from me childhood to initially
finding weightlifting yeah that's
interesting well I think really
interesting is that you've said about um
your capacity to be able to look and
then turn the movement just from
visually seeing someone else do it I
think that's definitely the mark of a
good athlete but everyone learns
differently and I find this even as a
coach now where sometimes I can say
something to one of the guys in coaching
they go yeah bang do it yeah someone
needs you to show them a visual cue of
them like you know you actually doing a
demonstration for them to understand
some people need to see themselves in
order to be able to interpret it what
they need to know some people just don't
get it at all yeah but that's the thing
and everyone learns differently and I
think I've always been very visual in
the way that that I learn
yeah the ability for you the
proprioception to understand where your
body is from having just seen something
I think is definitely the mark if
someone that has a natural athletic
talent and I think the fact that you've
started so young doing the golf swing
golf's very fine choice and move away
exactly very precise and I can say the
same for myself too degree I did cricket
for 10 years and that's exactly the same
it's a very technique based and when I
started with Jordan Reebok CrossFit
Tyneside I was able to pick up like the
first time that you taught me you do I
must look my girl must look the first
time you're talking I do tours because
awareness of your body and yet what what
is being asked to the 100 percent I
think that people don't like to hear
that there's a lot of natural a big
natural component in success within
sport because it takes away someone's
hard work capacity to get to the top hmm
but the bottom line is that some
children and adults that start sport
will naturally be able to learn
faster they'll be able to pick it up
more quickly so you've started you
weightlifting you're doing it up to what
three hours a day now
yes yeah I was doing up to what is it 11
or 12 year old what see what your lifts
can you rob Midway I think I can tell
you sort of what I was lifting at 12 I
would have been snatching around 70
kilos 12-day about 70 kilos clean joking
around 90 at 12 and 13 years on the air
50 this CrossFitters up and down in the
country that are listening to this
they're burying the head in the hands
right at 55 kilo body weight us thing
like that the ice competed the 56 kilo
class hang on you were 55 kilos at 12
years old yeah no no I would have been I
started when I first started I was 46
and then went up to 45 but the lightest
men's category is 56 kilo that was like
my character that I could be in it and
say yeah I suppose then we're nearly two
years in and it's about dear two years
in so I maybe would have been 13 when I
did those weights and I had won
everything like the bridge and the
thirteen's British under-16 under-17 Sai
broke the records thought I was the
dog's bollocks I was now gone from like
Billy no-mates in school to really
obviously popular kid insecure yeah like
and I got selected for my first
international then I would have been
without said 13 14 there's a European
Seventeen's in pavia so you're competing
against 17 year old to the age of 13 or
40 yeah but that didn't bother me I was
diagnosed my sister I've never lost that
that's the oven this thing I witness as
well cocky definitely I went to the
competition and end up getting six at
six broke the British rep my own British
records by kilo in each lift yes
finished 22nd out of 23 as only because
23 Banda and again I remember that
feeling of getting like working watching
the scoreboard going what's good for him
mother I can I agree but surely don't my
life there's no women out lifting me the
whole shebang and I was like wow so yeah
one of the best things that happened to
me though is so early on as a kid in
sport because I've very quickly realized
that it wasn't about being the best kid
in your country and the best at your age
you had to look so much further past
being the best in your pond if you
wanted to compete at the highest level
and yeah like I said one of the best one
of the best lessons I learned really
early on how humbling I suppose when you
said you you were kind of big dick in it
for a little while and yeah bringing
yourself back down to earth is probably
what what you needed yeah at the time
you obviously you don't notice it but I
look back and reflect now on my career
because I mean I've been doing it 12 13
years I've had a lot of years lifting me
and this set the free certain points of
my career that I pinpoint go that was a
turning point or that was when things
went to the next level so how did you
react once that happened what happened
to your training and what happened to
your approach to the sport overall yes
wherever the the next couple years he
coming back from that I decided that I
needed to work much harder in my
training and you know that I just
started working a lot harder than the
other guys but at the same time straight
after that so mm and coming to 2008 just
shortly after that first international I
actually ended up having my back injury
okay so it started off just being like a
nervy pain in my back when I was lifting
and I was that it just didn't feel
comfortable but it progressed to the
point where I couldn't walk I was in
that much pain how old
so 2008 so that's 10 years ago and out
of it about yeah 14 years old right and
yeah that's a young age to be having it
what feels like a severe problem severe
problem to the point where I ended up
having crutches for eight weeks but
could to help me walk around school
because that could've a thing I weren't
able to train you weren't able to walk
nothing's nothing and obviously that
made me like extremely upset even at
that age because that I was training
every day and that was alive yeah
already at that age
so we went to see it physio and it was
actually Tom Daley's physio at the time
Amanda booth because my coach when I
first started Michaela Brees was a calm
off gold medalist she'd been to the
Olympic Games she was my first coach so
she took me to see this Amanda booth and
she was like god this bad don't not seen
anything lies for go see doctor so they
went up to Bath University from Devon
Tassie a back specialist there and had
the scan and obviously the scan came
back and it was like there at the time I
had to do this that well thanks to Lance
it's sad to dehydrated dis dehydrated
yeah so basically obviously got fluid in
your disc okay
and so I know her feeling it's like
compressed so okay dehydrated discs so
instead of them being like that fit it
was like that so I already had that like
compression my disks and then basically
sacrum first vertebrae were fused
together so that put pressure then on
the disk above cuz obvious you'd have an
extra disk there normally if you imagine
when your back goes into flexion it
gives you a nice curved cut but because
mine was like this to begin with and
you'll still see well back when I set my
back the first bit of it stays flat and
then I get my curve but obviously that's
so much greater rot in it yeah but
obviously that disk then above where the
two a fused has to take more force yeah
and it caused it to come out basically
I've slept protrude yeah and slightly
and then because I was so young the bone
because my bones are growing the
osteophytes have grown over the top of
the disc like out over the disk to like
protect it I guess okay and that's what
was actually pushing on my sciatica
nerve causing me pain the pain so he
says if you've walked in and you're just
like a glossary look at back injuries
right yeah and the doctors not remember
going back at the bar for consultation
he's like
I've never seen anything like this from
someone your age he was like can we take
this to the world
you know medical conference to discuss
it that's the only problem and they did
need to call in an expert
yeah and in the waning he sought came
back and was like you have two choices
really if you carry on lifting you gonna
be in a wheelchair or you give it a go
rehabbing it and see what happens but
he's basically saying you need to stop
wait a thing so that was obviously
really upset me down and I guess I had
that sort of two weeks of not really
knowing what to do and then Amanda booth
came back to me and said that let's give
it go and just try and rehab it and
we'll just so happens so we went back to
working on the level core stuff and I'd
go see her three times a week for rehab
etc and at the time after a little while
I started just when I could walk et
cetera again I was in bed of pain
started snatching just the five kilo bar
and again this is one of the things that
I think and I mean Ben Bergeron didn't
really good talk about injury like a
while back and you know about when I in
his talk he was talking about how it
when his door a broker at or ACL in a
LaCrosse thing and it's like that really
like made me realize back at the same
point when this back injury happened to
me it gave me a point to actually
correct things that were wrong in my
lifting because of though I was a really
good lifter there was I was making like
little technical mistakes on my knees
used to come in when I used to clean and
I wasn't really strong enough for how
good I was technically yeah and I used
to crash on me etc my arms like little
spindles
yeah and it gave me time to sort as I
was rehabbing and coming back I spent a
year snatching just fifteen kilos so
working on fundamental
and technique in graining it which is
like why I think now nearly 10 years on
my techniques really good and really
consistent readers I had at that time to
correct those issues earlier on that a
lot of people don't because they keep
going keep going keep going
and then yeah they get by injury and
that's it or you just never be able to
progress because those technical
patterns are so there's a thing when an
interesting segue there so I started
boxing about three four years ago and it
was originally to do a white-collar
boxing fight against another promoter
who's a good mate and I looked at I
actually I've really really enjoyed it
and decided I'm [ __ ] I'm gonna
continue and went out to Thailand went
to Thailand did kickboxing in white.i
and stuff are there I absolutely loved
it what I found was that because I've
spent so long doing bodybuilding that I
mean you can hear that little click
there that's my wrist yeah I swear that
I didn't mean for it to happen at the
right time but Opie for the [ __ ]
exactly um just gonna pop it away from
the mic cause he makes up and I get
annoying sits off the audience so I'm
boxing and why found was that because of
the years of doing like chess press and
stuff like that my power of being able
to throw punches was super super high
but because my technique wasn't there I
actually ended up injuring my wrists
then that's all badly and I'm like no
this can't be the way like it can't be
that I'm too powerful for my own body I
don't even know how to throw a punch
properly yet what that was the case and
it sounds like the same for you you were
almost too strong for your own
biomechanics
yeah you were able to lift weights that
your body was what it's just yes I think
it's the other way brown but technically
like I was in the neighbor is enabling
me to lift heavier than my body was that
yes ready for but yeah the same
principle yeah book coming out from a
different side so you've spent your time
snatching fifteen kilos and yeah came
back 2009 so this is the heart war I can
remember doing another Europeans and
other juniors and I was successful in
those years
to the point where I finished coming up
to year five or six and I think through
having done that haven't having that
injury I started to question I guess
bits of what my coach was getting me to
do because I was going to competition
International hasn't seen other guys
that were far stronger than me lifts
think differently to me and I was that
to my coach while we'll be doing too
much deadlifts and pools and squats
there's the other guys and coach that
all you don't need that it's all about
you know speed and technique and I was
like getting to the point where I was
lifting as much as she was and I guess I
got to the point where I believed that I
needed someone who was lifting more
weight and understand what it takes to
lift that way yeah and now being in that
position or now like you know ten years
on I think it was the right choice I
made so we did have a bit of
disagreement over falling out and it got
to year six where you decide Sixth Form
College etc and I was still playing golf
at this point and I was playing to a
good level is playing off like for three
or four handicap alongside my weight a
thing like that I was good and my dad
was obviously really wanted me to crack
on with golf golf and I had to make
decision was gonna do this today so I've
ended up finding a way to think oats in
Bristol called Andy Souter and there's a
really well renowned weightlifting gym
it was the closest to Plymouth is we
could find a home and one of my friends
was going to university there so I was
like well I'll move to Bristol and join
this weight of thing gym and off we go
were you gonna get a college as well
like six form or whatever oh you're just
gonna go to wait the full time to wait
left that that was it I was doing that
single-minded yeah and I had good GCSEs
I had like six a star six days and four
B's four C's that did all like the
triple awards and all the epsilon side
good GCSEs and so said to my dad that I
want to move to Bristol to
my own way they're here at 16 and he
just led to me not you don't you know
certainly I went away for a couple of
weeks and I went on a computer did a bit
of research and stuff and ended up
finding a golf caddie Bristol hmm so
Matt's my dad said dad you know what
scrap weightlifting like I want to join
this golf caddy mean is that I'm not
stupid
he's like father he go but on one
condition so okay go on
he said I'll give you 200 pounds a month
for six months and if you don't find
your own way and six months you have to
come back home so I was like [ __ ] okay
well let's give it a go that's flying
the nest big stylin yeah so at 16 off I
went
hardly now the white mare and bum went
to Bristol and my mate was obviously
just started uni there and stepped on
his uni all floors for the first two
months of being in Bristol imagine
imagine freshers we went out got
hammered at my mates ID let made every
mistake you could make is a 16 year old
moving out from home and having no
responsibilities just do what you want
but the same time like great but had so
much fun I got to the bar managed to get
to stay there to the point when someone
actually dubbed me in for being 16 to
the security guy huh the reasons that we
won't mention and I end up having to
find a room that's around but obviously
living off 200 pounds a month was very
difficult 50 pound a week you like who
everything lie and it was tough
and I used to get the bus down from
North Bristol down to the centre of town
to to the gym and the gym was in simples
which is a notoriously like bad area
rough areas got a bad stigma behind it
like a and not now but at the time it
did but the empire sport stopped up
there and like I said this was a proper
gym like this is an old church and
anyone who went to the Empire it was
known everywhere you'd train properly
there's a weightlifting in there was
boxing we had like world champion boxers
coming out of there
mr. universe is everything was done to a
hi-yah
precious McKenzie training there like
the law yeah
so if we went there you were serious and
you say I get off personal you just walk
down to this to the gym and I guess he
got to mope month five of being in
Bristol and timed away at a time like I
kind of you take for granted all those
things your parents do for you washing
up washing your clothes in the corner
cuts our videos etc and yet had to grow
up really quickly I guess and it was
coming up - I guess now we're looking
about a year out from London 2012 yeah
was that in the back of your mind were
you thinking of when we first started we
was that the goal was it London 2012 I
want to compete in my home nation of
course that's like me and my dream was
always to go to the Olympic Games and
that was definitely in the back of my
mind and even in my coaches that there
was a good chance because when you're
living this is in your home country get
quite a spot so the qualification isn't
like how it is now where it's you have
to be like top ten the world it's really
difficult this is like you have you have
to yes you get quota spots this is like
yeah you don't have to be tops in the
world so you had three spots basic so
it's much easier to qualify um so yeah
it was definitely in my compass for sure
so um like cells used to get their walk
down through simples to the gym and I'm
in month five of being there and I'm
working out how I can try and stay in
Bristol some two months out from the
World Championships which was the first
one of the last qualifiers Finland
becames and I was I need to stay in
Bristol to do this and walked into the
car park one day and like I said were
described for the Empire was like old
church machine tall area but this is
brand new white Porsche 911 Turbo S part
in the carpark
I'm just like [ __ ] like I is you're
brave
yeah that is nice god what the [ __ ] is
it doing here yeah and I walked into
reception and I said to my coach and II
was behind the bar I said Andy who's
that who's
how's that by the car playing is his
name's Jeff he's in the main gym in the
bodybuilding gyms have fun have fun
and what's up into the main gym kick the
door open I had to shout at who's Jeff
and I brute the rooms I probably say
that six times the size of this room
it's quite a big long haul and it's
everyone in there like I said it's
serious showing them yeah and they've
all sort of stopped because that come in
the said there's Jeff and just on the
other end of the room and flat they're
doing bench press and he sat up and
here's what you want on Jeff
and just said fancy sponsoring me but
her thing I said to him what and he goes
well how much is it gonna cost and like
I said the time was living off 200
pounds month and I was like this
obviously got a few quid I need to be
here two more months I'm there 200 quid
get some trainers 500 quid so far too
quick then he went what a month and my
jaw sort of like hit that point bearing
mothers living off to in depends month
yeah everyone in the gym probably own
just about earned 500 Padma and this
guy's gonna give it to me they little
care so everyone stop what they're doing
they're scrap their sessions and they're
just watching this conversation just
give back and forth now and I went yeah
okay then you just went sound and just
let down I'm just kind of like that
really just happened but okay yeah down
and got on with my session and then
about an hour later
Jeff's come out he gone there yeah what
she bank details so I give my bank
details and sure enough the next month
fire equipment at my count and ran with
Dad up and I said dad and staying in
Bristol [ __ ] golf bomb exactly do try
and go through them throw you forget
down a bit down there right and I guess
after that me and my dad didn't really
speak so much for a while a relationship
definitely lights up when when apart I
think he was predicting that you were
going to wind up going back home
I don't think so I think he knew that I
was very determined to do what I wanted
to do but because we sort of drifted
I'll go back and tell you a little bit
more about Jeff because he's kind of a
really big part my successor my story
because from that moment on so I can
tell you about Jeff anyway so Jeff used
to race BMX as a kid and he was really
good BMX racer and he was European
number two good enough to go to America
turned pro and but unfortunately his his
parents not enough money to send him out
to America so he subsequently end up
quitting and stopping his sport but off
the back of that he ended up setting up
a telecoms company and now is extremely
successful telecoms anything right in
his own right multi-millionaire but at
the same time with the most downs were
nicest funniest guy you'll ever meet and
he saw me in a similar situation I had a
dream of you know going to the Olympics
he was very aware of me and my
circumstances and you know because at
the club I was obviously well-known of
what I had dreams of doing and he saw me
in a similar position to him as a young
kid but he was in a position where it
could help and so he did a lot of a sort
of poetic irony poetic justice in that
situation right that you happened to
come across a guy who was in such a
similar situation to you and then not
only was in a similar situation but had
the resources to be able to assess you I
think yeah definitely it's a stroke to
stroke it up for sure but the thing I
take away from that and the thing that I
tried because people go all sunny earth
that you manage to get sponsors no one
else did etc and it's this as simple as
if you don't ask you don't get and if
that wasn't the first time I'd ask
someone for sponsorship that was
probably about the hundred and fiftieth
time after countless letters I had sent
out and just no replies etc it although
yeah it's great but it doesn't
necessarily happen the first time but if
you have the balls to ask someone then
how are you ever gonna know do you think
that that little situation that you've
said
and the framework that's around it is a
microcosm to a degree for weightlifting
that people see you walk on to the
platform they see you snatch 160 180
kilos they see you put these lifts up
and they go well like of course you can
do that look how strong he is and you go
well hang on you haven't seen all of the
fails that I've done in the gym you
haven't seen all of the hours they've
had to go into of course and that's
that's the thing about any sport when
you're put in the the limelight and you
have to perform for that one moment and
no one sees that the backstory and
everything the sacrifices and stuff that
you go through along that journey the
walking on crutches for eight weeks at
the age of 14 and all of that stuff and
I mean like from that moment on you know
we went on and actually ended up missing
out on the run its way to our Olympics
for ancilla
it's heartbreaking for me Patong kilos
yeah but one two kilos I missed out on
it but and you know it's heartbreaking
for me and again like you you learn from
that experience and you know Jeff went
to me well you know what like why don't
we just carry on with this punch of
doing you try and qualify from try and
qualify for Glasgow 2014 what's what was
that is that's come off games
yes that's like your next biggest thing
really in weightlifting to the Olympics
in I guess for me that moment that
heartbreak that failure and the
disappointments to remember how it felt
that was like my catapult to make sure
that for the Commonwealth Games up
wasn't gonna be the same thing I wasn't
gonna miss out on being there but it
kind of worked both ways for me because
I made sure that you know I stepped on
my training etc and made sure I hit the
qualification total when I did and it
was great and I went to that competition
to take part this is actually what I did
and I had no aspiration for anything
more than just to be there and that was
again another big learning curve for me
because they made me actually think of a
psychological side of how you approach
competition performance and events and
but for me that like I said I all I had
was the aspiration to be that I end up
lifting
weights I was capable of and finishing
in fifth place and I think what if I'd
[ __ ] tried and actually gone into
that competition believing that I could
win and if I'd lifted out my skin
reached PV highs there probably would
have been a good chance that I could
have maybe snatched a bronze medal but
because I didn't believe that I was
gonna do any better than just be there
that's all that happened
do you think that that was an artifact
of not making it to 2012 I that thought
process I don't I don't because I'd
never been in a position where I as
competed in two major championships like
that so but did you feel like you'd
already accomplished what you wanted to
accomplish simply by being there yeah
exactly
and you know I think whether I lifted
five kilo more for a few less it
wouldn't have made any difference to me
because I went to be there yeah because
becoming at the time getting to the
Commonwealth Games was the massive thing
and no sidetrack a little bit here
because I think this is another that
valuable thing that I learned from
reflection on that was that like at
points of my career the things that I
thought were of most importance now I've
got older I've actually realized that
they weren't and like if I could go back
and change or change my thinking it they
would be that what sort so for example
like I used to hold my body weight down
like 56 kilos or 77 kilos or certain
weight categories far longer than ever
should starve myself used to live off
jelly babies and make myself sick so
that my body weight wouldn't go up had
no knowledge of any nutrition in order
to break a British under-17 record which
in the grand scheme of things means
absolutely Farkle no one remembers who
won the Youth Olympic Games hundred me a
sprint of it every one of them as
anything but the time as a kid and
growing up you think it's the most
valuable thing on earth and you'd do
anything to achieve it and just like I
did get just getting to the Commonwealth
Games I think what's interesting Larry's
perspective is something you naturally
get as your frame of reference is wider
and this is for everything right like
your first breakup it feels like your
world's collapsing let me out for you
like your first breakup feels like your
world's collapsing but ten years hence
you're like par for the course like easy
come easy go so to speak and you're
totally right I can remember playing
cricket and I got accepted to play for
Durham Academy and for me like I got to
warm up the Australian team when they
were playing at Durham against England
so I got to ball against Ricky Ponting
and like some of the best players on the
planet and I should remember thinking
about this is like the pinnacle of like
why can I share on that you're not even
on the strip you're like in the net
you're in the nets in the arse end of
the stadium and but at the time you've
got that you know me me so you're so
overwhelmed by the experience and you
know I think for young athletes and
young athletes they're listening I like
what you said at the beginning which was
that you you expanded that dumb what
you're perceived domain of competence to
be global it was that okay I don't just
need to be as good as the people in my
town or in my region or in my country or
even in like my continent I need to be
if I want to be the best of us why I
need to be the best in a period and I
think what's interesting is that there's
still little artifacts of that that
percolating through and obviously
there's someone who has made it to the
top of the sport it's interesting to
hear that they are still subject to the
same kinds of cognitive biases and
thought processes that a lot of people
will they sell themselves short off
their own yeah yeah and off your own
expectation and I mean going on from
that like I said that being a like quite
a big point I guess in my sport or
realization of myself and actually I
having like maybe even a thought about a
psychological process because prior to
that I think I think there's no way
sing with the psychologist and talking
about scenarios etc could ever make me
lift any more ways well when your
nutrition the zenith of your nutrition
is jelly babies the psychological
training is probably not Tom nervous as
a kid there was no support I mean
there's very little in weightlifting and
I mean up to that point
the men's team had had very slim amount
of funding up to the Commonwealth Games
and afterwards it stopped and after come
off games half the team retired they
stopped because there was at there's no
way that I can continue training this
hard etc baton except I was training six
days a week and it would be three of
them would be two three sessions a day
and the other ones would be one two
sessions of that so you know racking up
at least that nine to twelve sessions a
week you commit your whole life to it
and the guys would look at me and know
what 24 now I need to go and get a job a
job and earn money because this isn't
paying a thing and they end up quitting
but for me at that point it was like I'm
not gonna let the fact that I'm not
getting any money stopped me from
wanting to achieve my dream of going to
the games and that's again like my
second night I say the most valuable
thing I'd say is like there's any
obstacles regardless of whether it's in
sport in life there's always a way
around them or a solution you've just
got to beat that I guess pick minded to
want to be able to go and solve it and a
lot of people give up that really
quickly.i he says that we're going back
saying about traits of a good sportsman
or a good athlete they don't give up
that easy they go and find a solution to
the physics strange that stubbornness is
a virtue sometimes yeah of course yeah
of course but like yet great in this
sport yeah bullying situation in
relationship probably bad in relations
around us so yeah come off games is gone
and now he is out from the Olympic Games
and obviously that was well and truly
then my next biggest focus and don't the
whole way through this I've said Jeff
still there supporting me with various
bits and bobs and it got to the point
where I was about 15 kilos off after the
come off gains what I would need to do
in order to qualify for the Olympic
Games and the last two years prior to
that I'd probably put like maybe four or
five kilos on my total each year it's a
very small amount
yeah a tiny matter so it was going to be
difficult to sort of reach that and I
had to look at things and like I said my
training was banging I was working super
hard in the gym all that was good I had
to look at things outside of just why
did in the gym that could potentially
help me a performance and that's when I
started to look at nutrition start look
at psychology started looking my
lifestyle like lifestyle recovery all of
these other aspects and what I like to
see as like a spider's web of my life
and could potentially contribute to my
performance and I looked at I guess
we'll talk firstly about psychology
because were kind of on that and like I
said as a kid I had no belief with at
all that some guy could help me actually
put improve but I started working with
this psychologist one my friend's dad
mind Fricker
and two David Riedl and they're both of
the same schoolís or the Steven Steve
peers is it chimp paradox etc and I
guess the key things are gonna extract
that they helped me if my lifting one
was developing a process for when I'm
lifting so routine that I go through
every single time before a lift in order
to develop consistency and also it's
better carryover any performance that I
did in training into an environment like
a major championships because commonly
see athletes that can do by obeying in
the gym put them on a platform we go do
something different or lose their really
don't actually deliver on the debt so
they taught me to happen to drill a
process and the second thing was only
that worrying about the things that I
could control like so again that
outcomes were there just byproducts of
whatever the process was so I guess
those who thinks of are going is too
much death really helped me can you can
you explain what your process is yep or
you do a lift okay and this is some of
this really independent to everyone and
I think the sooner you become aware of
your individual process the better
chance you've got then of obviously
being consistent so for me I paced up
and down the bar back and forth I
stamped back behind the bar and I like
to call my pink box so this is where I'm
thinking about the to the technical side
of things that my coach has taught me
whether it's to stay over keep the bar
close etc my technical cues there and I
visualize myself and this is always a
good question because people was asset
do you visualize watching myself or in
my own voice yeah so I visualize
watching myself do it and executing the
lift and it being a great lift and yeah
so after that then I approach the bar
and that's when my like that's my
trigger then to just go through my
routine so my routine is always right
out first then left hand and then set my
feet I shake my arms I've get my
breathing controlled and then I set my I
start counting them 3 5 4 3 2 1 mutter
it very quietly under my breath when I
hit one I lock in and go and for me like
I always used to other issue which load
of probably the list as well as well and
anyway just wait the thing um right
before you come off the floor you think
far this is gonna be yeah we laugh
because you know exactly what going on
about and that doesn't change whether
you're in limbic apathy or was your
first day you go [ __ ] this can be happy
or I might hurt myself here but again
the negative outcomes like
one of your processes and for me just by
counting down before I left and going
like one like a gunshot
erase it distracts your mind from
thinking about those negative thoughts
that worked really well for me so yeah
that's that and that's the same for both
snatch and clean and jerk yeah okay and
what about X I've always I've always
wondered this once you count to one
and once the movement has begun do you
just let the training kick in in the
same way as a boxer doesn't think too
much but there must be a point in snatch
I can see that it's one more fluid
movement yeah there must be a moment
once you've cleaned the bar and then you
stand on it is that same thing but short
version of it so I get out the top and
the theme my foot comes in further away
my heels three two one bang so this is
that the same thing broken stick that's
awesome yeah that's a lovely little
framework for people to use and it
sounds so stupid that I've stepped up to
the bar
like in workouts or even like going for
Mac's lifts and I've just like
approached the bar like gripped it a
whole bridge for the best but I don't
have it I don't have a process and
that's why you won't get consistency
yeah again to draw this back I feel like
I'm talking about a sport I haven't
played for nearly 10 years now cricket
an awful lot today but the best
analogies that I can find and for that
you can imagine as a bowler runs in she
got a bowler who's running in from the
back of his run-up especially if it's a
fast bowler you've got five seconds from
when this guy sets off until like when
he hits the crease and releases the ball
and during that time a lot you've got a
long full lot and time includes a are
there any like you end up getting
trapped within your own thoughts and
that's the last thing that you want
especially when you're talking about
someone if pitching a ball 80 85 miles
an hour if you think you don't have time
to react you need to allow whatever your
movement is to just carry through yeah
and just have the the essences of where
the fielders are positioned how you know
he typically balls what what the pitch
is gonna be like all of the little
things that come through you need to
still have those in your mind
not consciously but this this
interesting that you you draw the
comparison because you have to remember
in weightlifting likely starting in
cricket in football your action is a
reaction of something else whereas I've
seen weightlifting it's not the same a
little control of your yeah the total
control so you initiate the movement
where you want to and it's there's
definitely a difference there in terms
of you having that split-second to make
a decision yeah whereas like for weight
the thing you're just exiting that
process the same as in a you know golf
swing and that's what I love about
individual sport and by being like I
guess the only one there a spotlight on
you because at the end of the day it's
down to you then as to whether it's a
good lift the bad left or the execution
and you know you can have a great
performance one there and you know ok
there's other people involve a sport
teams etc but it's down to you and if
you have a [ __ ] there you notice it's so
it's strange it's both it's both
liberating and terrifying to think that
if you've lifted if you've snatched 180
kilos before in the gym you can snatch
hundred eighty kilos on the platform
there's no reason why you can't which
puts the power firmly in your hands but
it also means that the failures in your
hands as well hmm and I think that it
must be for the guys that are at the top
level of the sport and the same for
CrossFit like especially with when you
look at stuff like regionals hmm they
released the regionals and events in
advance the athletes will have tested
the events at home they know exactly how
fast they can go there maybe even during
a practice weekend why they've gone okay
we're going to go back to back to back
this is the timing statistic but this is
quite easy for me to answer that that a
thing because this is the thing that
people don't really take notice off when
you talk about someone's performance in
competition versus their performance in
training when you're in training you've
slept in your own bed the night before
you've woken up and eaten out your same
cereal bar you used to leaning from
with your same cereal you're lifting
with your favorite bath with your
favorite plates on your favorite
platform and you've got your favorite
coach there with you watching you train
and that is your ideal environment to
perform and that's why I don't think
everyone's different in terms of like
you know what competition can bring out
of you you know some people do that best
in competition something but this I
don't think it's necessarily a surprise
that people sometimes perform best in
their own environment because when you
travel to say Berlin sleep in a hotel
maybe get woken up by the cars that
you're not used to go down a
breakfasting there's [ __ ] food there et
cetera regardless of whether you've done
the workout a lot before you're not in
your best environment to perform and
it's only the real top athletes that can
replicate as much of what happens at
home in the common the travel of
competition they really perform so you
go back to controllables and
uncontrollables to a degree that you
said it's the second part of your mental
strategy and you totally write that I
said it must feel terrifying and
liberating in the same degree but as you
say if you take everything back to the
process and you grease the groove and
you have a plan and you stick to the
plan and the plan is I know that I
perform best when I eat to these kinds
of food pack mini bag like yeah I know
that I need to have silence when I go to
a hotel room back to me it looks that
like bar roll doubles yeah and this is
the follow-on from this story is gonna
be quite funny for you now so I've
identified all these things what I need
for competition etc my best stuff etc
dancer my nutrition started working with
the nutrition company and that by food
prep Tech cetera and there's good bits
and Babbitt to that but carrying on from
what we are actually discussing so I
know I need to perform the weight of
things to accept from my boobs prep
everything so whenever I go to a
competition it's all there
exactly how I haven't practiced it in
training yeah and six months of for the
qualifiers now for Rio 2016 I've gone
away in
dunwall is sorted out my nutritionist
when I'm asleep recovery I lived like a
Mormon for six months that went at the
same time every single day for six
months ate the same thing every single
day of six month didn't have a drop of
alcohol didn't socialize that it's a
very monastic lifestyle yeah - I'm
sufferer - robot turn myself to a robot
for these the sort of sacrifices and
beyond that that you need to make so of
course I knew I mean even go back into
childhood I'm we can count on one hand
how many times I spent kicking a
football around in the playground I can
count on by all our hands how many
holidays I missed out on parties I
didn't go to because like for me there
was much more bigger things at the age
of sixteen okay maybe I hadn't like
tried to drug and like done all the
things that you know there's a 16 drop
but I traveled to that maybe like
majority continents of the world and
seen that 15 places which is like 16
years old not many people get the
opportunity to do and that was for me
more important than those things so it
swings and roundabouts I wouldn't say
like your heart done bite but there's
other things you know I think what
you're doing is you are you've chosen
your values at an early age which not a
lot of young people can do you've
decided what is our value to you and
what virtue and integrity with that
value percolating through looks like and
you've gone okay I'm going to get after
it like I'm not gonna allow social norms
or what I should be doing at this
particular age to dictate how I know
yeah how I need to behave and again we
come back to the stubbornness and the
pigheadedness in kind of the desire to
chase what you feel is your own your own
path and in this sense yeah it's
absolutely a virtue you know it can be a
nightmare for a parent trying to bring a
child up who's got this sense of I like
direction and idea because they're not
gonna compromise and it can be a you
know a nightmare in a relationship it
can be there's a whole host it swings
and roundabouts again but you know if
you want to be a good athlete and you
don't compromise on things like it's
probably a pretty [ __ ] good
foundation to stuff yeah so go Matt's
like we were saying like this
six the six months have gone it's now
competition day of the qualifiers for
the Rio 2016 Olympics that my my day of
reckoning d-day wherever you want to
call it now I'd had special wait the
things she was done that were black and
gold that made I'd had special night
weightlifting suit was black and gold I
had like a night track suit had like my
special logo stitched into it brand new
pants brand new socks at everything a
snapback black and gold that Sun that
ball get I was like but this is exactly
how I've been in visiting it for months
this is my day and this how I was gonna
get all of this prepped and ready to
rumble
and anyway Jeff's can pick me up in his
car just Oh plan I'm driving up to the
competition and where's the competition
it's in Coventry and we're about an hour
away I guess from the venue now and I'm
watching the competition on the
livestream like just seeing how my
friends and people were getting on and
the guy I fought with guys what with
that for her he's got similar waiteth in
suit to me and it was just as I had that
thought I went no I had as a Jeff pull
the car over man I needed to check it
back right at the back of the car
bearing more than 60 70 competitions
past big major conditions at this point
I left my weightlifting shoes I'm away
it's in super her to the biggest day of
my life to something I've thought about
every day for six months and I was like
[ __ ] like we were too far away sort of
missed weigh-in to get back had to end
up getting Jeff's wife to bring up one
of his old weightlifting suits and my
coach just so happened that one of my
old pairs of waiteth issues in his car
so going from like the most prepped I'd
ever been exactly how this day was gonna
go so all of a sudden Mike Spann a
friend in the works like my suits not
there but do you know what and this is
why I like when people ask me to
stereotypical about anything now or in
competition and not because
for me I learned from that day they
regardless of what happens if you
prepared well enough something that you
could have stuck me in a pink tutu that
day and I would have still lifted the
same because I was that prepared for the
competition
so I've rocked that dusted these boots
off got my suit on weighed in and the
competition began now it was there's a
really good clip on YouTube of the Dean
will make sure that the link is yep oh
yeah of the mo of the actual fight for
the qualification between me and another
way that's called own box or really good
lifter and I must have known going in
that it was gonna be between you two for
this well for my weight category
definitely and then my best friend who's
in a lie awake I agree Gareth Evans was
also in the mix but it's done it was
done right points and but I knew I had
to be own like minimal quiet and
notoriously were me an urn of compete
it's been very like back and forth as to
like I when he win etc he always used to
snatch more than me but I used to with
clean Jack mourn him so the snatch comes
first right yeah so anyway we've gone on
to gone on through the snatch and I've
ended up beating Owen by like a quite
fitting is like two kilos in the snatch
which is that unheard-of and I was like
for this great start perfect actually
153 anything and I was like this yeah
done this pretty much and Owens open I
was like 175 my open it was like 185 and
I was thinking that one night I easily
open on 185 stuff what I'm not 10k on
notice and his openers gone up for fact
ladies come out on that 182 which is
like his PB I for poor no for his first
if I thought fair play is going for it
he came out and he did it in a playmate
I come out did my 185 them but I fought
he goes ahead now and then he's gone
that one eight nine and I was going 190
anyways her fault yeah no problem
whatever yeah and he's come out done one
eight nine so he's like ahead now again
I'm Bonnie where he bastard [ __ ] the bet
so now my second left that I've hit one
ninety and I thought pass it now there's
no way night he's got another left in
him and sure enough he comes out one
nine three and makes it it's made a 12
kilo PB on his final there and he's
night for some reason the way the
numbers were I thought that didn't
matter that he got one nine through I
thought I was still in the lead yeah and
now I'm in the back like chillin like
this I don't even need to see my last
left of one my coach comes out he's so
you need to make this lift you need one
nine three no I was like no and I put
one known for and it's fine mm-hmm and
he's a young one I first put one name
for nipple and I put my hat on and of
spam my hat background so I take my hat
off cuz always lifting my snapback and
put back on and off or went out but
nothing had fazed me and my everyone is
like on the edge of their seats like and
it was like a British record and I've
come out and I've cleaned the way one
lone for as I'm standing out of me I
flew off my mouth why swallow I don't
know just swallowed it down and then
just nailed the jerk and it was like
that was the only way that they was
gonna go like regardless of the scenario
this is what I say that when you prepare
for something that wow
they didn't matter that was the outcome
for me for that day ronk it wrong shoes
did MA all of the worried before all the
anxiety before throwing up in your mouth
some guys lifted is 12 kilo PB but
because you've greased the group that
hard and you have you've done the work
you're able to trust the process there
the outcomes almost inevitable mmm and
then that was me on my on my way to rear
get on your [ __ ] way to Rio yeah
that's amazing but you allowed to lift
in a snapback I was the first person to
start doing it and cuz I saw I'll
explain my reasoning for
because an issue when I started doing it
a lot of the weightlifting community was
like that's really bad you shouldn't do
that it's disrespectful but for me
you watch wait this thing a guy walks
out he lifts his way makes some sort of
celebration
sometimes it was back at the back you
get no understanding of connection to
that person as an athlete as a performer
it's going back to like we say you don't
see all that stuff that goes back
whereas like I'd love what I do and I
want to show a little bit of my
personality a little bit of my charisma
when I'm lifting somebody's signature
yeah so this is me this is me slap back
a bit of me and instantly when you see
that you can't like a little link I
think I do where's the snap back about
that person just for seeing the red snap
back yeah and that was my reasoning for
doing it and yeah it made me feel
comfortable when I did it and I didn't
care that people didn't like the fact
that I wore it it was me and you know
it's cool that and it's cool that it
it's allowed in the it's counted as part
of your body so if the bar is to touch
or if is to fall off it'd be a no left
okay but yeah it is what is in that
nowadays you'll see they used to only
ever be like when I started one type of
weightlifting shoe they would be the
same color there be one weightlifting
suit so everyone's in the same suit the
same shoes coming out lifting the bar
the same boring as [ __ ] yeah it's
different now because of CrossFit yeah
there is like multiple different
weightlifting suits multiple different
shoes so if you do have any sort of
inkling of fashion sense you could put
together something that almost looks
like a planned out thing so it's
different it may be but yeah that wasn't
that was my reasoning for doing it
that's cool I think it's really it's
really interesting I've got for the
listeners at home Johnny who is a
national level
power lifter was making me laugh the
other day as he said that he couldn't
believe in powerlifting that when you
deadlift your socks aren't allowed to
touch your knee sleeves if your socks
touch your knee sleeves that used to be
a rule in weight the three red Larry red
lights yeah
Yussef once got three red lights on a
lift for putting his one foot on the
platform like on the corner of the
platform basically off-camera before his
clock had started like just had his foot
unites resting your foot
how does all those sorts of rules and
weight of thing as well okay with that
you wouldn't know just some like somehow
having a hat it's like yes it's no
reason yeah how it does is because they
changed the rules only a few years but
so that Muslims could female Muslims
could compete in weightlifting so they
can whether it's a job yeah so that they
could wear that so that they had to
class there any head wear as part of the
body which is then how wear army lies on
that the hashing me give me the snapback
I'm taking this a little bit but that's
how wearing a snapback is yeah that's
funny so brought it forward to real yeah
Wow so I guess going there like going
back and talking about kicking out I
guess cuz for me as a kid like as a
athlete reps in your country getting
your kit is like one of the proudest
moments ever and it is one hell of an
experience I dive heard stories about
people that have been to the Olympics
about what kicking out is like and I was
like like kidney connoisseur basically
I've been to the Commonwealth one base
and have the same as like what the
limits like they absolutely gonna not
smooth it so you go into this big cords
NEC and you have a personal shopper and
you go through right different sections
so you start with like formal wear and
you've had like this suit made for you
with like you know the Olympic crest on
etc and every detail of it it's got like
really individual to you and we wore
that when we met like Princess Anne and
any royal to you all you suit you get
these cool shoes and then you're going
to like village where and then this is
stuff that you wear around the village
tiniest stacks and stacks and stuff as
you get that wet weather gear for that
rearing it the booty actually need it in
the end
like just senseless about any possible
scenario and then you go into like
training where and then footwear what
were you most excited about
probably the trainer's of the footwear I
was all that there that we're sorting
there's a few jumpers and stuff that I
had seen I can't know who I'd say my
certain top who's my favorite piece that
we got but you get so much stuff and
yeah you get you accessories but then
the final bit is quite personal because
you imagine that I was the only male
weightlifter going there was one of the
female going so when it comes to making
what they what you perform it they're
essentially making you an outfit for
your biggest day of life and it's just
you that's gonna have that so obviously
for a weight lift that you weightlifting
suit and you go into this waiting room
for a minute and they have like a
[Music]
mannequin of you know just know is it
your night men want if you are not a lot
of up the tradition that I'll make sure
they have a yeah so they have mannequin
of a human and it's like a big reveal
you walk through and this you're lifting
so unlikely a new car and they pulled
the yeah but I've made it just feeling
they're so proud of it because obviously
they've done it from scraps to be like
for you in it is really cool in do you
like something for stuff and then you go
through cuz Audi sponsored it so then
you take all your stuff onto the bags
the suitcases have got like six bags
like different suitcases and bags and
all of this stuff and that was very
special and that's when I guess it
starts to feel real going he came big
stylin yeah
and then the next thing was the holding
cap in a better Horizonte and bearing in
mind like I said as a weight lifter you
have like no no one really cares that
weight your thing it's not very popular
famous sport there's very little funding
for etc and all of a sudden you've flown
out to this purpose-built place or like
fitted out place for Team GB preparation
for the Olympics
and we get to the airport and it's like
get on this bus just three of us three
of us two witnesses in the coach on this
bus and it's like an eight police
motorcycle escort through Belo Horizonte
shutting roads for us as we're coming
through like we're celebrities are
really in Donald Trump's just yeah and
that was like weird like I said all of a
sudden me now just as important as the
sprinters or the boxes and stuff like
that and you get to this hotel nice
hotel again normally we'd get put in the
[ __ ] it's totally your mind
and basically all these people that are
there for you for what and anything you
could possibly think of one is a physio
full-time as a doctor there's recovery
people nutritionists sleep helpers and
all sorts of stuff they'll get you
whatever you could possibly want and
it's really wigs like I said that and I
was always told that don't do anything
you don't do at home so if so I never
had any of that home so that you kind of
just don't make them don't use it you do
what you used to do and eat what you
used to and stuff but taco possibly yeah
exactly like they're coming out with
like caviar
yeah bond okay all right yeah just to
interject there do you think that there
is a it definitely sounds like there's a
disparity between the level of support
that's given to you but anywhere which
isn't the Olympics and then at the
Olympics there's like this perrito
distribution of like nothing nothing
nothing buy everything and it's
overwhelming and it's like going back
like you said about it being like in
competition scenarios it's all of these
things it's all of a sudden overwhelming
like you go to training while we were
there and they've got 15 cameras
pointing at you it's flashing but you're
training I was like this is like I'm
gonna be back in the church no I was
kind of loving it a bit you don't mean
it's like this is simply you can embrace
it that is your power right yeah well it
was nice to feel like important the
people when it's coming firs if you're
not interview and stuff like that it is
you think I said
personality that you almost took energy
from that yeah definitely I wouldn't set
that necessarily energy that would have
caused me to compete or perform any
better but I'd say it made me feel
special and you know proud of why it
achieved and at the same time very
draining like and the point from the
qualifiers to that to the actual Olympic
Games with very small motors of six week
window and this is the thing with our
sport I went boost the wall to qualify
that there's no way the man who are can
you hold that level of performance for
six weeks and without your body fall
apart do you have to taper and I tried
to hold that standard of lifting now to
like what did the qualifiers but it's no
chance that wasn't a lot more sleeping
tablets painkillers everything you could
imagine just to be able to lift and
we've flown down to the village now our
about two weeks out from lifting and I
just said to myself forward in the
village I said I don't regardless of
what happens on the day you've got to
remember this experience and that day
like as the best day of your life
because you're never gonna get that
opportunity again in that in regardless
whether you go to the Olympics again
that one day you gotta live with that
for the rest your life so I wanted to
make sure I enjoyed it so I just said
that to myself and I kind of like took a
little bit pressure off myself in terms
of what my training and stuff was going
like and then we went into the village
and it's like you hear the stories about
the Olympic Village and I'm writing
together what everyone's tuned in for
yeah it's like it's not like that well
even even that it wasn't like missed out
when you're in the wrong she were in the
wrong area right no anything I was but
it just thought it didn't seem like that
about what everyone sort of him imagined
so we went on to go into the village not
see that I was just the only
weightlifter male weightlifter but
everyone else is like a team of hockey
players a team of sevens a team of like
athletics and it's just the weight
lifter like standard like the way this
is
like putting the corner yaksas well that
win any medals and they were like right
do you want to go in share a room with
the ping pool a ping pong table tennis
guys or you can share the gymnastics and
I know a couple of the gym now sides
from the Commonwealth I'll stay with
them there you go that's fine you have
your own room but you in the cleaners
that cupboard fine room is probably
about this thing is absolutely fine a
walk-in and Max Whitlock is in there
doing his stretches on the floor like he
comes straight up is that either into a
bags in my room and and we all just like
click just so that says me max Whitlock
NAR Wilson Bryn Bevan Christian Thomas
Lewis Smith and Nathan Hall and Niles
just rang you there right yeah yeah so
we're all like um seven lads in an
apartment young lads this prank was
going on there's supergluing
toothbrushes down to tops and all sorts
of render stuff like because just
sending lads in the apartment and they
really made me feel like one of their
team like straight away I'd have team
meetings with them like I would go for
breakfast with them dinner with them
that was really nice that to kind of
gain some routine but definitely for the
first week I was Brown the village like
a fangirl like you so many celebrities
everywhere you looked you know [ __ ]
photo selfie but hey these people that
you like you've only ever seen them on
TV and then all of a sudden the day in
Coco Pops ah yeah and so I was like wow
basically for the first couple of weeks
taking a lot of selfies and that lots of
famous people and then it was he who is
your favorite person he got selfie with
hmm I got I got lots but I'd say for the
reason I want the most famous but for me
as a kid I was a grown up playing cough
and Justin Rose was like a bit here and
we're sat in the queue waiting to get on
the bus to go to the ceremony and that's
like
big thing there miss mo excited sad as a
kid since even way before then I'm
watching the ceremony on TV and AB all
of a sudden eyes him open is only Nakia
on my way to go to it myself and they
were just kept bout to get on the bus
and I've seen Justin Rose stood there
and I've probably one I've got I haven't
asked for food and I've gone over ass
and phrase it yeah no problem had a
photo and then he just start started
chatting to me as I saw what support to
do program ended up getting on the bus
together then and sat together for like
45 minutes on the bus you damaging
yourself now yeah and but like at the
same time having the most normal
conversation like we are and then he
this is mrs. face times and he's our oh
yeah I'm just so ever sunny is a
weightlifter like hey this roses missing
weird and then we get off the bus then
we started walking you get like walk
around like the house is basically
before you pray Dinks is all done in
country order yeah and he started that
telling stories and about like being on
the tour and Tiger Woods and like houses
next to each other Barbados and all
these various stories like golf related
stuff oh wow how lapping up yeah and
like Andy Murray's there as well that in
a couple of the other tennis guys and
then all of a sudden we're there and
we're just about to walk in and I had my
phone out like that that try and video I
take photo and I just thought no there's
no way that you could capture what that
experience felt like in in any sport
picture and like you know that this is
one of the most bestest moments ever for
me like in my life walking out to that
Stadium the size of it
everyone's looking at you and I managed
to get like viola front row right next
to Andy Murray so Andy Murray Steph his
massive flag and then on their favor
[Laughter]
that's symbolic the size of your flag in
size definitely but anyways so yeah
amazing experience that and you
afterwards you're like almost like a SAP
like that's gonna say how long did I
sink into sleep arm because yeah I think
that did but after that incredible
experience that and then you kind of
like getting towards opening that
competition day like the various
acquaintances that meetings with other
athletes then and I will come back font
Andy Murray because obviously he got
asked to be the flag bearer and I guess
in them media Andy Murray comes across
like you know very emotionless quite a
lot some some would say directory yeah
and he's not like that at all and I was
very fortunate to spend like sit down
have lunch with him one day when we were
at the school and meet him there because
we had like a school outside the country
and I got to spend a bit more time
listening to him talk and chat and once
he started to talk and you know you got
to listen to him more actually like my
opinion he's just stuff a little bit
socially awkward and he's by no means
that arrogant or you know he's just a
little bit shy and not I think with all
of like the you know Fame and everything
he's had he doesn't find it is easiest
to express his emotions and that was
really like
I guess humbling to see that someone's
it's that successful and it achieved
that much is still like almost a little
bit shy do you think I got me it to him
now yeah definitely definitely from that
experience in the same with you know
Justin Rose that in him giving me that
the time of his day like knowing like
how much you know I looked up to him as
a kid to spend time with him and on a
level and the same with Greg Rutherford
and like children for a triple jumper
Olympic gold medalist won everything and
like I'd be sat down having food to is
that grow could come up how I was
training sunny good and it's like and
still now like Greg left watches made
Instagram story about every day and we
chat
make it in it's like these guys are like
super size but it makes you realize that
they're no different from anyone else
they're like exactly the same as me and
you they've decided redic the huge
dedication to whatever they've wanted to
achieve and I think it's an interesting
point there that you talk about to do
with the way that the meat that athletes
are portrayed in the media like you can
through hard work and dedication and
natural talent and all the rest of it
become really really good within a
particular discipline that has no
bearing on your capacity to talk to a
camera at all and I think that in this
day and age where social medias
transparent window into people's lives
and there's such an interest in athletes
private lives you know some footballer
signs for a different Football Club the
story gets 10,000 retweets some
footballer cheats on his wife with
another wife it gets 50,000 retweets you
know I mean like it's almost like
everything's become reality TV show eyes
now and people want a narrative that's
constantly going on and you told you
write with the Andy Murray thing
although I've heard you know that
rhetoric like Andy Murray like miserable
Scottish guy and you think oh hang on a
second
like is he or what happens if you are
not someone who's super comfortable on
camera yeah how does that make you come
across actually it makes you come across
exactly the way that he's coming across
is that this person has decided to be
chosen to be good at their craft and now
has had all of these other demands put
on them I mean I will [ __ ] like that is
that fair yeah and now you're Jubilee oh
you're judging him not based on his
performance like you're doing good his
performance thing like leave him alone
yeah and yeah I think people want the
whole package now right like and
especially I guess sponsorship money and
all the rest of it people buy into the
character as much as they do the
performance but then this is when people
go back to me and is commonly asked
questions sports people what
your biggest inspiration mother who's
that your idol and for me having been
through that experience that Olympics
it's not about now an individual and
individual person its traits of people
that have been inspiring and it's like I
said that the way in which you know some
of the most successful people in the
world is so humble that for me as an
inspirational trait and I find that
through more now than a specific
performance that anyone's done yeah
inspiring but interesting we were
walking into the gym earlier on and
there's a guy who you won't know but
Nathan Moffatt he'll be listening and
Nathan was walking out he's been in
Newcastle in Newcastle for years these
moved to Australia and his goal is to
make it to regionals I think within the
next couple of years and he walked out
recognising he said hi to me turned
around recognized you shook your hand
and he walked away and then turned back
and said oh you help me with my clean
over Instagram DMS like a few months ago
thanks for that and you're like oh yeah
like Cheers no no problem you know like
one just one guy and I'm aware that you
know it's not me and Andy Murray in the
Olympic Village but to the same extent
it's the same core message right this is
it's exactly that you've got hit the
nail on the head and this is where like
through for me now when people do send
me direct messages when people do ask
refer and it's like it's still weird for
like someone in wait they like me and
like that's attention but I do do my
hardest to like you know even respond if
it's a smallest little thing because I
remember what it felt like having you
know Justin Rose be like that with me
and think that you know if I can do that
small thing by you know offering someone
a couple of words of motivational advice
or liking their video and then be
jumping up and down for the rest there
it cost me nothing but you then passing
that same sort of message on in terms of
what you aspire to be like and that's
not to self reply to every single master
of ever been set because this is not
realistic but as much they can I always
do try to do that and it's purely from
you know having experienced that myself
good role models to a degree of people
who have made it to the top of the sport
of course so what was it like stepping
up in the black
in Rio yeah Wow again it gives me goose
was not even thinking about the actual
Italian tell tell me what it looks like
so first off actually I want to find out
I'm sure that some of the people will be
interested at home anyone who follows
ATG or will see it won't look great for
him yeah so both of them amazing
Instagram accounts you should follow
them they do a lot of backstage stuff
right big competitions and they'll track
if you go on the YouTube channel they go
like dick and balls they'll go from like
empty bar to find a water lift and
they'll track everything and they'll pop
it up so talk me through your routine
you pack your bags you've arrived at the
lifting Hall what happens yes it does
really seem like a little bit of a blur
now thinking back because that day for
me right from start to finish I've never
felt that way on a competition day I
think because like you know like and
it's again it sounds weird because we're
talking about just another competition
but you've dedicated we've talked about
my whole life today so you know you're
11 years deep yes but all of that all
the things we've talked about has
funneled to that one moment and it's
really hard to kind of in capture how
that feels
and I never felt emotional in a
competition experience before like that
and it was kind of like really hard to
kind of you know keep your focus that
you would never want any other
competition in terms of like your
routine your warmup and stuff because it
was like I wanna remember this and enjoy
it and said take soak everything in
because it's it's such a special day to
me and I know in myself
everything that I've sacrificed for that
one moment and I remember she going to
get weighed in and then you sitting like
a what doing you what kangri me 9 4 kilo
class bee-boop ok and you there's a room
out the back has that loads of drinks
and food and stuff and I had my food and
went for my weightlifting suit and
again which is like quite special I'm
peeling your suit
I put mine on it just rips it off right
my [ __ ] hand but luckily I bought a
second one second ones on fire might
sell ripped my suit huh mmm and you go
into the warm-up room and like you get
given your platform and we had a few
furs and stuff and I had this grin on my
face that like I just couldn't get rid
of right I was so [ __ ] happy like
like my cheeks hurt by that remote from
the moment I woke up till like that
whole day that's that smile and green
just did not leave my face and we've got
to now the obvious in the warm-up room
and then you get called for presentation
which is kind of like right this is it
that competitions that start and I
remember coming out walking out and them
saying Sonny Webster Great Britain and
my eye it was so hard not to cry that
and I still have it now that thinking
like don't cry so many people are
watching don't cry don't cry and i found
that held back and was like you know
because you know like so many people
have sat there watching you know you and
it's that and then I looked up and
Jeff's in the crowd came flat to Rio to
watch me and another friend of mine
Susie was there like who came out to
watch who's against know me since I was
young in my career and you know it was
real special moment and to go back in
then afterwards and you have to kind of
like try and throw that away and just be
like right you're here to perform and
lift but it's so difficult that's a
that's a good point just before you go
on I'm gonna be in ejecta do you think
that the the ability to think outside of
yourself and soak the situation in is
contrary to focusing on the greased
groove of the movements it seems to me
like soaking the situation in by its
very virtue is going to take you out of
that routine take you away from what
your use
- doing in every of every other
situation but in every other competition
other than the Olympics yes but I think
that is the most difficult one to do
especially in like you know Asia is your
first Olympics but even people say to me
that I've been to more Paul like now I
know what to expect the next if I was to
ever go sit in fits again what that's
going to be like and you can kind of
kind of prepare for that a little bit
but even people that have been multiple
time said that everyone's their mamas
moment if they're you're thought that
simply by the games it's like the
biggest biggest adage in the world right
so yeah I think like it does to a degree
but I had to kind of put that to one
side and remember that was there to lift
but you got remember as well I'd had the
worst couple of weeks training up to
this van and like I kind of just warmed
up and you know I tried my heart and
like the coach just said to me they've
said you wanna bring your weights down
and you know just go through some easy
this you know as I haven't trained my
whole life to come here and sandbagged
myself and look back on anything I could
lift it more I would rather have tried
my hardest and you know got one left and
so at least I went lose the war I just
didn't make it and that's exactly what
it yeah I stuck to my client went out
and I made one snatch and then miss
manette know everything miss moment and
snatch got my second and then miss my
third and then for the clean-and-jerk I
got my first key injure myself in dirt
and then missed my last they were like
they were big waste I could have done
but like every left regardless of
whether I missed it or made it I still
finished the lift and soaked in and
enjoyed the experience and like a lot of
people would have looked it in looked it
upon that oh he didn't try hard enough
or he didn't look like he really cared
but like for me for me that was a bit
annoying because like people don't know
what goes into that but I didn't want to
walk off the platform kicking myself and
think like I know I wasn't in the best
shape and I knew I could have gone
lighter and sound back there but I now
look back on that moment
still the smile on my face and with no
regrets and that's why I wanted to do so
regardless of what you know the public
perception was etc because they don't
know all that stuff that I just said
about you know mostly my body on my body
was it six weeks to tape it down and you
know I mean they don't appreciate that
they probably would need never seen it
before there's good and that's their
perception but fine I don't know it
myself because at the end of the day I'm
the one who has to live with that day
that I had tried as hard as I possibly
could and I enjoyed every moment of it
every second of it and I look back on it
now with a smile on my face I retell the
story with a smile on my face and I will
do again in 20 years time probably so
yeah a very special moment but you kind
of go on from that peak the best day of
alive and then reality is here and
you're back at home and no one cares no
one's there with the big money pop for
you like sponsorship deals checks it's
kind of like you get back on with your
normal life and all of a sudden you've
sacrificed your whole life for this one
moment and now you're back and it was
difficult I think initially because I
did feel quite depressed coming back
from it and you get those Olympic blues
etc and it only wasn't really until I
started doing the seminars after the
Olympics where I kind of found my
passion back before the sport again if
you like brothers it sounds like a
version of PTSD almost yeah it's like
you've gone through such a nation that
there's I could come down on the other
side of it never people talk about all
the time I think it's genuinely a thing
Olympic Blues is that they like the
ether but yeah I see
so let's get on to the seminars now so
you know that's how I got to know you
was through your lifting online through
the you call it
circus lifting yeah it's kind of been
branded that now I don't know if this is
a substitute I guess for me the surface
if thing came about because I watch a
lot of weight the thing on liner for a
lot of weight if it counts and I don't
know like it's gonna be a surprise but I
find it boring as [ __ ] watching people
just posting a snatch way and I can't
imagine how even more boring is for
someone who has no understanding that I
invested in the sport yeah but no like
understanding of the weight and how
heavy is you watch some you know I get
now though crazy do come out and snaps
119 you start [ __ ] and that's it I mean
as a another example to bring it back to
ATG or hook grip they'll have on their
Instagram they'll have one video like a
hundred frames a second and obviously
the reason that they do that is so that
the technical experts can see just how
close the pulleys to their legs just how
much they dip under the bar etc etc
regardless even the normal speed videos
it's ten fifteen hundred guys on there
or snatching ways these that same lifts
to me that's a bit boring whereas that
for me I'm not oh [ __ ] it's just fix up
a bit like do something a bit crazy add
a bit of a convex together and it just
gives someone something different to
watch other than the same [ __ ] the same
to this mmm-hmm Dean will make some of
these appear as we are talking around
the screen thank you video guiding and
so yeah that saw the surface if that
came about so I've got for people who
haven't seen it or who are watching it
what's going on around the screen around
our heads at the moment it's me sticking
various different movements lifts
together until basically I don't have
energy
but it kind of shows like I guess real
control of the bar and understanding of
the technique in order to be able to do
that it's extremely difficult doing it
please don't try at home as people I've
done it I said that is it is essentially
that but I think like as well and I
missed a massive chunk of my story out
because I have actually done a degree in
sports performance of Olympic
weightlifting okay which I missed our
studying at Bart University during I
guess that time when I was trying to
qualify for the Olympics
mm-hmm which that completely messed up
but did four years at the University
purely at Bath on sports forms Olympic
weightlifting and that's an incredibly
specialized sports performance for
Olympic weight yeah so what you do at
Bath is everyone in my class was either
in sash for their sport of six of them
pians in my class and a class of only 36
people so everyone was national
international at their sport and various
that group you do the course based
around your individual sport so there
was for example a rhythmic gymnast in my
class so it went to the Miss in 2012 she
did her course around rhythmic
gymnastics so we do different sectors so
for example nutrition shooting nutrition
for religion assets had leadership
weight thing there be a psychological
aspect and you relate everything back to
sport and do what your dissertation is
that show your studies what was he doing
and what was your title and the efficacy
of caffeine in PowerBait sports and how
effective is it yeah but it is effective
obviously and higher doses for pave
sport so I was talking I was looking at
like real high doses we're looking like
600 and 800 milligrams of caffeine were
you they just want like about 1215 cups
of coffee something like that yeah a lot
so see yes did you see the study that
happened at Northumbria University was
given like 10 grams of notes 50 grams
instead of 50 milligrams yeah so I'm
gonna give him 50 grams of caffeine or
two of them and they ought to be you
know the RV yeah so I was doing that and
during that time I was training
throughout the day I'd go home he get in
my car at like 9 o'clock at night drive
to university which was an hour away
from Bristol study 10:00 to 3:00 for the
morning drive her seat for three hours
and then do a gantry so how long well
last f4 yes
how'd you in term time of that time yes
I think they're lovely fingers that's
trying to juggle training with that was
extremely difficult so yeah I kind of
sidetracked that I might miss that out
but I'm going back to what we're saying
about the circus lifting the coaching
like that was kind of like I guess adds
a little bit to you know what I do now
in terms of delivering the seminars
coaching people help people the
techniques etc I have done the theory
side of it as well as much as the drill
new self into the ground with that right
yeah so now you're as you move forward
coaching people I know that you're going
and doing these seminars where you've
got between groups of what 10 and 50
yeah what's the biggest seminar that
you've done so far I've probably had 40
people once but like for me ideally 20
people is a really good number because
any more than that I don't feel like I'm
giving each person any personal
attention and I like everyone my
seminars just much about having fun as
they are about learning so for me that I
want to try and make sure that everyone
leaves that day with individual
technical pointers but also feeling like
they've met and hung out and spent time
with me and got to know me as a person
I've been seminars before where there's
50 60 people and you may even not get
one direct person from one not direct
word from the person that you faith
gonna sit so yeah I think for me yeah I
think I sir
so if you don't go your goal at the
moment as you move forward obviously
you're having a throw anyone who doesn't
know who make sure that Sunny's dates
for his tour in October October and your
beginning in October and finishing in
January going that way or up that way
around the world sorry yeah
through Doha and Australia and finishing
Miami and broadly beyond that beyond
going and I guess accessing as many
people as you can up to this 20-ish
limit where do you see your career going
from that is that sufficiently
fulfilling for you or are you eyeing up
trying to take some young blood and get
them to the next level in a sport or I
think for me like like us our dedicated
12 13 years of my life solely to being a
competitive athlete and you sacrificed
so much like I said already in that
process and 24 years old down there's a
lot of things that I've missed out on
and things that you know not ever change
and go back I wouldn't but there's
certain things that want to do and live
like a bit more of like a normal life
I've been able to travel a lot more this
last few years go on holidays go to more
parties and you know I wouldn't spend a
little bit more time for myself and
focus on business side of things in
terms of with my seminars and you know
I'm really enjoying at the moment the
[Music]
getting to meet more people building my
I guess it's very few people out there
that provide education for Olympic
weightlifting and you know wanna sort of
like become a expert in that field in
terms of you know wanting to help people
improve with their lifting obviously
I've made a bit of a impact in the
CrossFit community in terms of giving it
a go myself and obviously a lot of the
gyms I go to the coach at across the
gyms so I'm enjoying learning something
new a new challenge it's extremely
humbling doing CrossFit workouts and
sucking at them because like I said the
most weight lifting stuff now I've been
doing it most
my life we can do if my eyes closed yeah
but make me run a mile and I'm that but
that's really nice and I'm enjoying that
feeling of having to learn a new skill
being a novice of something yeah and you
know applying the skills I learned
through weightlifting to something else
so that's enjoyable and I'm not really
thinking I guess too much further ahead
as long as I'm happy and I'm enjoying
what I'm doing then that's kind of like
the the key main focus for me at the
moment I do have in terms of aspirations
to compete again I don't know 100% yeah
I mean I've got out I wanted to get
olympic games I did that one last thing
I haven't done that I wanted to do as a
kid was when I come off gold medal and
there's potential to come back and do
that in in Birmingham in 2022
mm-hm which is yeah it's potentially
something that I made a cap
near-real-time so would you be prepared
to make the sacrifices to your lifestyle
again again to do that this is a thing
that and it's a really good question
because I know what it would take to go
back and do that and I think there's
kind of good in that respect to know is
actually if I wanted to achieve that I
know what you're in for
ya know I'm in fourth and I guess I'd
have to look at it close to the time I
couldn't definitively say right now that
that's a die-hard priority of mine has
been the back in mind though hundred
percent it's in the back of my mind and
it definitely like features as a thought
as something that I've kind of a stone
the one that stands up left but at the
same time weirdly over the last I guess
six months more I guess attention and
aspirations has gone to maybe wanting to
compete in the CrossFit Games or Mike
especially after coming back from
regionals and watching the atmosphere of
the competition and the sacrifice those
guys put in to what they do is it's a
hell of a challenge but again that I
know what sort of training and
dedication it will take to reach that
sort of level of sport and until I mean
a situation where with the best coach
with the best training partners I'm a
hundred percent focused to that goal I'm
not gonna do it half-heartedly I would
quite rather just enjoy what I'm doing
it sounds like a common thing that sort
of come about through this as being a a
single mindedness V or you've understood
where broadly where you're going to one
degree and it's funny that it almost
sounds at twenty four years old like
that you're taking kind of like a semi
retirement seventeen retirement yeah
where you're just like okay like or you
know you've done you did four tours in
Afghanistan like I'm gonna just give me
a break
and I'll go back out there maybe I've
still got the skillset like and it's
cool it's it's interesting to think that
you know it wouldn't surprise me if
young athletes suffer with burnout I'm
sure that a lot of them do give him my
body arrest as well like it's nice not
being in as much pain there was day-in
day-out before as I was training and I
do have other aspirations outside of
sport in terms of business aspirations
and other things I want to achieve you
know so yeah there's definitely other
things outside of sport for me there
what would you need to
what would your talk need to be do you
think ish at the Commonwealth Games to
be able to pull a gold I know it's
heavily dependent on what this is
nothing like I mean I think can happen I
know that it needs to be probably close
to a 160 snatch which I've done training
obviously I ran that 160 mark and clean
jerking around the 200 210 watt per I
mean so topeka this yeah big numbers it
needed an improvement but those guys out
there that are doing more
that you know may continue to go on they
may move up we carry all the weight
categories have changed out for me wait
the thing as a sport it's it's really
struggling and I think although across
fits raise the awareness of it a lot
more I think that now like that is a
more attractive proposition for me in
terms of like where the sport is and
where it's going and and you see could
you see yourself competing in CrossFit
over the coming years yeah I mean I'm
holding them building yeah I'm doing a
charity one for but other cancer with
one in October in London yeah so I'm
competing that I'm a now being against
it yeah I quite like my body I'll go
ahead tell me you want a single rep my
exact George of you yes that George and
the lean machines do not see it's a
pretty solid team well I mean even if
you don't win you've probably got the
most Instagram followers if you probably
yeah that's that's number one but no
yeah definitely like I'm not I'm not
putting too much pressure on myself
because like I said for once in my life
I don't have to yeah that's cool it must
feel very liberating to have something
that's it's kind of close to what you've
done before but also it must feel like a
holiday like a holiday doing the same
thing you've always done to a degree
like it's kind if there's a lot
crossover and there's a lot of things
that I think you're actually having done
CrossFitters assisted my weight of thing
like and made me learn about the way
that I train and how hard I train in
terms of you know this may be doing a
little bit less but training a little
bit smarming taining what still
different levels of my lifting so we
talk about this a lot we've mentioned it
on the podcast with Jordan Paul and Tim
before about just how sophisticated the
sports becoming now and it's interesting
that you've got this massive lift off
little you know weight lifting not so
long ago included it was a clean and a
press right and then it was a clean
injure those three components like power
lifting yeah and that changed but
because it's been around for so long the
adolescence of the sport was like [ __ ]
knows when like early 1900s
it'd be something like that yeah but
with CrossFit like the the site Tony
existed since like 2002 the literally
the site has existed since then and the
event they've done at this year's
CrossFit Games 30 muscle ops for time
was on the site in 2002 that's six years
ago you say you say this that but you
look at a lot of people thought when I
because obviously Mac phrase it was a
way to et cetera and when they started
hearing that I was doing weightlifting
new CrossFit training and they go wow
it's gonna be the next Matt Fraser and
it's like hang on a minute
that they I'm not being funny how that
now there's very like I reckon my value
of actually competing is in the athlete
is more valuable than my skills as a
weightlifter because of these but even
then like you look at what these guys
are lifting then lifting you're enough
like top level weight lifting weights
anyway but it's a completely different
energy system like than it is when
you're doing a 1 rep max lifts there's
very little carryover sit like my
ability to know how to train hard is
more valuable than my weight of thing
abilities that but yeah I picked up a
lot of the movements quickly but more
going back to like what we're saying
about having an understanding of the
body and how it moves but there's still
so much to learn it's a very principled
instead of specialities to a degree
isn't it that you understand how to eat
and how a train and that's that athletic
ability was yeah I mean it's interesting
that CrossFit is bringing to the
forefront of people the the forefront of
the general public's mind weightlifting
and and strength sports in general it's
made it a lot more sexy meaning there
for me knew a lot of the time when we
speak we we make jokes about like power
lifters like you know you are really
really strong but you are cursed with
like not very interesting-looking kits
but you know like you look across pit
and it's like a [ __ ] fashion show to
a degree like any like everything
everyone's able to dress cool and all
the movements are is
a bit like community / people will call
a cult I'm saying yeah it's it's
strength sports for the for the [ __ ]
Instagram era right like this is weirdly
very attracted to a very wide diversity
of people and I think it brings people
together really well and that's why I
think yeah people do class as a
community because you know you can have
your four-year-old mum of to training
with 20 year old lad that's just been
out on the piste night before chocolate
birds you know I mean train together and
they can be completely different
abilities and what to work out together
and bring two very different people
together and it be lower level yeah I
think it's one of the only sports that
you get like that which is taken why
it's typically very individualistic as
you said you know I'm sure that you had
a lot of friends that you weight lifted
with and they would stand around the
platform while you were training and
support you and stuff like that but
there must be times that it feels very
lonely or extremely lonely and that's
why I said that after training that long
like it's very independent for the last
or four or five years in my career yeah
this shit's boring and that's why I say
to people is very boring sport going
into a room full of people training
together as you know it's exciting yeah
I agree
I think it's it's a strange strange
worlds to be in where you've got such a
diverse number of people that are all
doing the same spot and it's really cool
to to hear that you're maybe gonna make
that transition over I wish that we
could go on but am I gonna die for a way
I need a way you guys so much event too
much not that they need a beer
I'm full of fit aid and I know that char
clubs stop serving wings in about 45
minutes so I'm gonna get my bag again
it's court Wow yeah we've been going so
man thank you so much for coming down
I'll make sure can you tell the
listeners where they can find you online
please yes so mainly on Instagram sunny
Webster GB I do have a Facebook page as
well sunny Webster but any inquiries
you've got about anything
whether it be seminars programming etc
as well you can email me at info web app
info web start - perform stuff on web
star star not Webster Webster
exactly so man thank you for coming on
I'm gonna getting you back we've got we
could talk so I might just I might just
like video one of our well I won't video
one of our FaceTime cause that's a bad
idea but maybe one of the more PG one we
could have gone into like the some of
those various from last that's in spoken
for NGO detail man well you know
although you know if people want you
back in the comments below in YouTube
I'll make sure I'll give sunny a kick
every couple of weeks and I'll make them
log on making go in and have a little
bit of a browse through the comments so
if you are watching them YouTube make
sure you do that subscribe one in wisdom
please share the episodes if you want
follow sunny online here video guide
Dean thank you very much and yeah we'll
see you next time okay
[Music]
you